people watch videos on the internet and
they take the advice and it's the wrong
thing to do they don't understand that
there's two components to advice and
when you're a beginner everything that
you get for advice usually leads you in
the right direction because anything is
better than nothing the problem is the
more advanced you become it's just like
driving a NASCAR when you're going two
miles an hour you can make an adjustment
and doesn't really swing the car very
much but at 200 miles an hour a slight
hair off and the whole car blows up when
you are more advanced the advice needs
to be more nuanced it has to be the
right advice for you specifically in
your context and it has to be at the
right time and so you can have the right
advice at the wrong time and it makes it
the wrong advice how can I take this
make it contextual to me personally and
to where I'm at in my current Journey